Music is the heart between the mind and the hands.
It has no religion, no sexual orientation.
It brings people together.
In the music industry, I have definitely had to knock through some doors.
When I first started out, I was told to dress a certain way,...
...to wear my hair a certain way.
"Girls can't dance like that."
"That's not what sexy is."
When people say we can't do something, I love proving people wrong.
I just hope that some young girl sees this and they wanna take ownership of their powers,...
...and use their superpowers to help change the world around them.
Yes, I can be a woman of color.
Now, I can own my own recording label,...
...sell my music independently.
I can be Janelle Monae...
...and I didn't have to change who I was.